[音楽]
鍵かかっ
てる
閉じ込められてる
な4回だから降りるのは
無理さすがに飛び降りたら死ぬな
う
んん黒い上前を開けるってがかりは電気を
消すと見つかるぞんIQレベル90まで君
らの泣きかえええこれ多分行けてる
な俺これ行ける
ぞこういうことでしょ電気を消すだからで
とんときはいはいはい
え枕の中来た来た来た来
た
あれはい中中ってそういうことか
うんおうあゴキブびっっくりしただ
だるえ待ってめっちゃめっちゃいるんだ
けど何これどういうことえぐいえぐいうえ
うえなんでなん
で
あ
あったゴキブリの中に紛れてたこれで
出れるので
は来
た
え
はめ社長さんの家に謎解きを仕掛けさせて
いただきましたおお全ての謎を解くことが
できないと一生家から出ることはできませ
んので一生なるほど分かりました脱出ゲー
ムってことですね謎を解かないと外に一切
出ることはできませんついに来たか4億円
謎解き脱出ゲームじゃ行き
ましょうさっきIQ書いてあったから多分
レベルがあると思うのよねここが4階1回
目指していきましょうかここ4階だから窓
ぶち上げて飛び降りるとかできないんだよ
なであれば階段かエレベーターです
ね来ないんだ
けど壊れてんのエレベーター
全く反応しないんだ
けどさあ階段です
ねなるほど
[音楽]
どうやって開けるかですねちょっと
探そうさっき
なんか
見るから怪しいんだよなこれシークレット
ボックスそして黒い
封筒うんアンサーシート4問の謎を解き
答えを書き込め多分このシークレット
ボックスを開けるヒントになってるん
だろうなIQレベル130がっつりな時だ
[音楽]
なあこのABBCDを埋めるための問題が
ここに4つあるってことかAからくか
傷ワ貝額
虹でなんかオレンジと青に分かれてる
オレンジがなんか金かじになってて青が別
の何かとえどういうこと
[音楽]
だあああ分かった分かった分かったこれ傷
って木と図なのよこれはわとんかといがと
く2とじうんきかじでしょう逆から行くと
ずはいがに入きましたズワイガニ
ですズワガニってなんやズワイガニって
なんだえあでもこれでAのアンサーシード
に
書き込めるズガニ次はB行きましょうか
黒い部屋で手がかりを見つけて時計あえ
黒い部屋か
行き
ますいや相変わらず黒いなあ衝撃的な黒さ
だ
[音楽]
ね何あなんかでも白い髪とかが落ちてる
んポイント
ポイントなんか
何枚かある
のえ南とここにもあるんだよ満回
あここにもあったか感お菓子の感かなどう
いうことなんだ黄色が満回ポイントなと
感全部4
文字関係ないのかいや全部運が入ってんだ
よな
満
南感やばい愛俺105か105もないのか
考えろよく考えろちょ書こ1回被ってる
文字ないんかな
ポイントポイントと南頭もかぶってるな
溶岩もここでかぶってるからなんか見え
そうで見えないぞ数字は何なん
だ全部に共通するものじゃなのでこれ多分
この4つの何かが入るんだよここは運が
確定してるえっととなると南東とポイント
でで被ってる文字はとなのよねここと確定
じゃない溶岩と満開で被ってるのはうんと
かもかぶってるな2とかがかぶってるから
2番はじゃかだな多分3番満回の中でどれ
ともかぶってない文字まてなると1も
なんか何ととどりとも被ってない
から1はなだなこれで1と2と3が出まし
た南東の中だてどれでも被ってない文字が
なんで1がなで2番は感と満で被ってる
文字そして運以外なのでかですで3番は
満開の中でどれとも被ってない文字
ま仲間だ来たぞ仲間だ
これえ俺これいつ出れんのこれやばい
ぞ仲間はいよしよしよしよしあと2つC
行きます部屋に隠された手がかりと
組み合わせて解けIQレベル110
トランプのマークがありますねスペード
ハートクローバー
ダイヤ部屋に隠された手がかりアンサシと
よく見たら場所浴室って書いてあるの浴室
っぽいす
ね浴室来ました失礼しますいやオンチだわ
なんかお風呂に沈んでるしここにも置いて
ある何これでこれなんかお風呂場にもある
んだよなすごいとこに待ってる
などんなところにヒント
がこな
ヒントあここにもあったここにもありまし
たうわすごいとこに
あるここにもあったもうなさそうかな
ちょっとこれを元に考えようこの4つどう
いうことだなんかでもこう繋がるんだよな
とりあえず置いてみようか1回スペイダー
スペードのとこに置いて
みよう
ハート
なんか形ができてきてるなクローバー
スペード
ああなるほどこの順番で読めばいいんじゃ
ないか1回バって書くねもう
123キキュキュキュはいで順番に読むと
この謎の答えは太陽き
た気持ち太陽だ
よし太陽次は
D何これ9文字あって8が3つ目赤いヨヨ
が地球何言っとんねんIQレベル
115ちょっと上がってきたねアンサー
シートに3匹の青き目の竜がいる部屋
ブルーアイズかブルーアイズ飾ってたんだ
よ夏にこの部屋だと思うんだけどな
[音楽]
ここにブルーアイズがいるから多分この
部屋だと思うんだけどこの9マスとこのキ
マス一生説ないこれ頭使うぞでも多分
間違いなくリンクしてんのよこのキマスと
キコの棚はあとはこれを解くしかないや
よいしょヨヨがここだからでヨヨが地球の
マークになってんだよ
などういうことだそもそもDの答って何
文字だっけちょっと見てこよう文字数から
さ予測するのも大事な気がするんだよな4
文字だ
88ってこれってことだよな多分さすがに
そうだよなで8の場所は絵でしょでブルー
アイズでしょこの3つ目は多分クヨヨの
場所はレえっと地球はこれじゃん
地球あエクレアですねこれ来たんちゃい
ますこれこれ来たんちゃい
ます
エクレあよしよしよしこれでこの数字右下
に数字があるからこの順に書けば
シークレットボックスの開け方が分かると
書き
ます赤い枠に
なえ
いれよ赤い枠に名前
入れよよく見たら小文字が2個あるね
小文字が2個入る
YouTuberここにいます名前入れ
ます
ねうわこれ小文字でもう生息できたなワン
チャン俺のIQがぶっ壊れてれ
ばはじめ社長そして2番シークレット
ボックスの番号を導き入力しよう
んあああ分かるこれこれ赤い枠よく見たら
右が点線のやつとか両サイドちっちゃい
点線とかいろんなやつがあるのよで両方
ちっちゃい点線のやつは絶対地なのよ矢と
世に囲まれてるこれだからこれ赤枠実は
どれが入るか決まってる説あるな1番右が
点線なのはこれしかないので刃ですねで次
が両サイドちっちゃい点線だ
から矢と世に囲まれてるとこなんで地です
多分左が大きい点線で右が小さい点線
しまた地かな同じ形だから地かな次も歯と
一次もは最後もちなんかなはい
878打ってみ
[音楽]
ます
わーあったこれでようやく出れるのか俺
は
来
たやった
[音楽]
ぞ出れまし
た
ええ別の髪があるぞうんなんや1階と2階
の間で解けいいいいいいいいもう玄関すぐ
そこなので行っちゃいましたわもう
行きましょう行きましょうもういいもう
クリアクリアクリアクリア
クリアクリアクリアクリア出ます出ます出
ますもうすぐ出
ます
くそ最悪やこれを解かないと出れなという
ことか1階と2階の間で時計IQレベル
150いや
俺の空はもっと高い裏から出る
ぞ表玄関と裏玄関があるのでねうちは
ささっと出ればいいんですよちょっと待っ
てくださいね開きませんよ
もう解きます1階と2階の間ということは
もうここしかないんだよ
なあえめちゃむずそうだけど多分これ
組み合わせて問題見るんだろうないやIQ
レベル
150俺でギリだなこの模様を見つけ出せ
左から読み導かれる数で鍵を開けろんこの
模様見つけ
[音楽]
出せえ1階じゃないのかななんか家の
カーペットああいう模様だった気がする
やっぱそうだよねこの模様が
ね多分これなんだよな左から読み導かれる
数で鍵を
[音楽]
開けろこれ問題作った人やばいなよくうち
のカーペットで問題を作ろうと思った数
数えればいいとかなんかなとりあえず数
数えてみるかわかんないけど
123でこのこっち側12え
32絶対そんなわけないでしょIQレベル
150で4桁の数字入れれるから入力する
だけしてみよう0032で言ってみ
ますうん違うねどういうことだ問題よく
読めマジでわからんえっとゲームマスター
さんもしよろしければですねヒントみたい
なものをいただけないでしょうかその文字
を囲んでる緑色のような枠どこか過去の
問題で見ていないでしょう
かこれってことですかそれ
です
無理ですよIQ150やばいなちょっと
戻ってみよっか過去にヒントがあるのかえ
見たっけこんな枠戻ってきちゃったよ4階
に過去の
問題
あこれとかそう
だその枠になってるまさかこのボード使う
とかなのか多分これだ同じ枠に囲まれてる
ぞ俺の予想だけど多分このボードを使うん
ですよ多分だけどこの絨毯の
模様と同じ配置になってるのよこれ10段
のこの模様が4か7だったらこれと同じな
のよ4く
1234567一緒ですで左から読めば
いいからあオオ見えたこういう読み方ここ
こここうだこここここうです
200525っぽく
ね0205で売ってみ
ます
け
た
嬉しいようやくこれで出れ
[音楽]
るってことですかね
また
だああまだすよこれもう1個ある
な多分だけどこれなんだよなこれが
おそらくラストですねやばいIQレベル
180ついにここまで来たよこれ溶けたら
もう天才の部類なんじゃないかそして
ついに問題分すらなくなった黄色青白緑赤
色だけ置いてある
な考えろ脱出は目前だどういうことだマジ
でわからんぞ黄色引く青何が残るかみたい
な感じなんかないや違うなそして俺これ
気づいたゲームマスターさんはいこれは
ペンあった方がいいやつでしょうかそう
ですねペがあった方がいいですねそうです
よねそんな気がしました入力する場所が
数字じゃなくてベットになってるから多分
だけど英語に変換するんじゃないかなって
思った考えろどういうことだとりあえず今
出てきてる状況としてはこの下の式に
グリーンは出てきてないのよホワイトも出
てきてないやけにブルーが多いイエロー
からまずブルー引くってどういうことなの
でも答えがアルファベットだから英語に
直すとか意味ないよ
ねいやアルファベット変換は多分違うな
関係ないNもない
1回カラーで押してみていいです
かダメでしたいろんな色使ってるから
カラフルだからカラーかと思ったら違い
ましたこれ動画見てる皆さん分かります俺
マジでわかんないんですけどさすがに
ヒントをちょっともらうかなゲーム
マスターさんよかったら何かヒント
くださいますでしょう
か今開けようとしているのはシークレット
ボックスですよねあシークレットです
シークレットボックスの開け方をすでに
知っているはず
です何言ってるんですかシークレット
ボックスの開け方を知ってる過去にどう
やってシークレットボックスを開けたか
考えてみ
ましょう過去
[音楽]
に1回戻ってみるかこれこと持ってこう1
回前のがヒントってこと
か前のシークレットボックスと今開けなき
ばいけないシークレット
ボックスあお点線とかやっぱ意味あるんか
なアンサーシート赤い枠に名前入れよあ
これがシークレットボックスの開け方
シークレットボックスの開け方一貫してん
のか赤い枠に名前を入れよだからこのここ
に名前入れればいいんか俺
の
ん枝はめか
枝はめなのか絶対これはめ社長入んないん
だよな俺3文字なんですよ名前が枝
はめこういうことでしょう行く
ぞもこう
でしょ
こうこうでこうなってて
こう
こうこうるっぽくねなんかこの剣のこれち
1回外に書いてみて
いい
[音楽]
く
CACALCなのかこれCALっぽくね1
回綺麗に書いてみて
いい枝の絵ってこうだもんねカだねよく見
たらでこういうこと
でしょこれ引き算じゃなくて
Cの可能性あるぞ
[音楽]
来た来た来た来た来た来た来た行きます
よ
えあれ鍵
はちょっと待ってなんかIQ200の最終
問題来たんだけど何これちょっと待って
やばいS=インテグラルDの3xえっと√
-DGちょっと待ってやばいやばい何言っ
てんのこれ自の歪みの調整と重力に関する
コート待ってやばすぎるこれ最後の鍵は
1234で開くて書いてある解かなくて
いいってことちょっと行ってみようか現
さんこれはも解かなくていいということ
ですかその謎を解けば外に出ることができ
ますこの謎を解くことができればいやでも
ね最後の鍵は123で開くって書いてある
から
[音楽]
ねちょっと
待て
数字ちゃうぞ最後の鍵1234で開くと
いうかこれ数字ちゃうぞアルファベットに
なっとるぞえっとゲームマスターえっと
1234打てないんですけどその謎を解け
ば開けるための最後の単語がわかります
ちょっと待って突然IQおかしくなっ
ちゃってる何書いてあるかも分からん俺
これ思ったんですけどこれね謎解きじゃ
なくて数学なのよもうこれまともに解くの
多分絶対ありえないから何かこの問題に
ヒントがあるはずなのよIQ200でしょ
違う違うこれはIQじゃない数学や物理や
どこかに何か解るヒントがあるはず鍵
1234で開くって書いてあるけど
アルファベットなんだよなゲームマスター
最後の鍵は1234で開くって重要ですか
重要ですちか今最後に開けようとしている
鍵は何色の鍵ですか黒ですね黒い上前の
開け方を知ってるはず
です
[音楽]
1番最初
か1番最初だな戻る
かやばいこれやばい
ぞ何回分往復してるんだこれとりあえず
戻ってきた
[音楽]
けど黒い上前の開け方
は
電気を消すと見つかる
ぞどういうことだこれを持って下に行こう
どこかの電気を消せばいいのかやばい
ちょっと最後の鍵は1234とか黒い上前
の開け方とかちょっとやばいな情報が多い
なとりあえずゲームマスターのヒント通り
黒い上前を開ける手掛かりは電気を消すと
見つかるからどこかの電気を消してみよう
電気消すば分かんのか
何かこれと
か
何も出てこない消し
ますいや関係ないかいや絶対ここな気がす
んだよ
[音楽]
などうやって消すえ俺こう消したことない
か
も違うよなえこれどこだやばい謎解きに家
の構造問題起きてるけど考えろ配線よく見
たらこう繋がってる多分ここら辺なのよ
[音楽]
きっとあった多分これだこれは謎解きじゃ
ない消し
ますついたわこれだな消し
[音楽]
ますなんか光ってる
ぞなんか光ってる
ぞえ何これ
ブルー
ライト
は今今見て見てなんか矢印が見えるんだ
けど分かるかな1がB2がE3がS4がT
っぽくないこれブルーライト当てたら数字
がアルファベットに変換できるぞBEかな
ベストかなわかんないけどちょっと売って
み
ます
pestどう
だきっ
[音楽]
たああ
はあN
[音楽]
ZK
H